Is Jesus in the Talmud? Yep. Here, right
here again, cuz they're going to try to
tell you, "No, Jesus is not in the
Talmud, Sam. You're a liar, Sam. I don't
see Jesus IN YOUR BLOOD LIBEL. YOU'RE
GOING TO GET SUED
by Alan Dershowitz.
Blood libel, Sam.
All right, here we go. All right.
Do you know that in order to try to
avoid persecution
is that
in certain manuscripts of the Talmud,
they change Jesus' name to Balaam?
Balaam.
Do you know that? A fact admitted
by Jewish sources.
Do you guys know that? For example,
quoting here the Talmud, I got to find
where exactly I quoted
Babylonian Talmud Sanhedrin 106.
Here, the name Balaam is Jesus.
Okay?
And then I'm going to show you Peter
Schäfer who cataloged the extent
manuscripts of the Talmud,
the ones that have survived, and he
shows you there are copies of the Talmud
that have survived where
the name Jesus appears in those places
that speak of him, but then there are
other copies where his name is removed
because of the persecution. So, we have
actual manuscript copies preserved where
the places in which Jesus is mentioned,
his name is there intact, they were not
removed. But then he compares it to some
later copies where the names were
changed because of the edict in 1531.
Right?
Focus now. Let's read here about Balaam.
Balaam also the son of Beor, the
soothsayer, did the children of Israel
slay with the sword. A soothsayer, but
he was a prophet. Rabbi Yohanan said,
"At first he was a prophet, but
subsequently a soothsayer." Rabbi Papa
observed, "This is what men say, she who
was a descendant of princes and
governors played the harlot with
carpenters." That's how they know this
is about Jesus. Because they go,
"Balaam,
his mother was a descendant of princes,
cuz Mary is a descendant of David. But
she became a with carpenters." You
get it? The attack on Jesus. Joseph the
carpenter who didn't sire Jesus. Mary
who's a descendant of David, royalty,
but she played the So, then
Balaam becomes Jesus.
See it there?
Now, what
does the note say? Are we making it up?
Is this my spin? Here you go, footnote
42.
Ship Draggers versus Rashi, Herford
Christian Talmud suggests that Balaam is
frequently used in the Talmud as a type
of Jesus.
And where do I get I'm going to show it
to you. Where am I Where am I quoting?
Though no name is mentioned to show
which woman is meant, the mother of
Jesus may be alluded to, which theory is
strengthened by the statement, she made
it with a carpenter. The Munich
manuscript has
H in the margin instead of H, a singular
instead of plural, carpenter.
All right.
Where am I getting this from?
Here.
Right there, boom. Babylonian Talmud
tractate Sanhedrin folio 106A.
And here I put Jesus. Oh, there you go.
H is real, right? Sees us as a covert
allusion to Jesus.
See that?
So, in order to hide the identity, they
call him Balaam who's also cursed, and
ironically,
right? He
in
Yet Jesus
in boiling
See that right there?
She was a descendant of princes and
governors, played the harlot with
carpenters. Allusion to Jesus, see?
You got it, right?
Again,
Balaam being used as an alias for Jesus.
Babylonian Talmud Sanhedrin 106.
Now, watch
how old Balaam was when he was killed. A
certain man, meaning heretic,
said to Rabbi Hanina,
"Hast thou heard how old Balaam was?" He
replied, "It is not actually stated, but
since it is written, 'Bloody and
deceitful men shall not live out half
their days,'
it follows that he was 33 or 34 years
old."
This is how they know it's about Jesus,
cuz supposedly he was killed at 33.
According to the view that all the
Balaam passages are anti-Christian in
tendency, Balaam being used as an alias
for Jesus. Phineas the robber is thus
taken to represent Pontius Pilate,
and the chronicles of Balaam probably to
denote a gospel.
Now, there are some scholars that
dispute it,
but the evidence seems clear. He's
supposed to be Balaam. Balaam is a name
for him. 33, cut off.
His mother was from princes. Mary was a
descendant of David.
But she played the harlot with a
carpenter.
Joseph was a carpenter.
Even the Jewish encyclopedia, right
here.
Jewish encyclopedia.
I thought I gave the name, dude. Hold
on. Oh, Balaam, right here.
Balaam, right here, you see? Jewish
encyclopedia. What does it say?
Henceforth, he became
the type of false prophets seducing men
to lootness
and obscene idolatrous practices. Balaam
became a picture of a false prophet.
The name Nicolaitans given to the
Christian heretics holding the doctrine
of Balaam is probably derived from the
Greek-sized form of Balaam, Balaam.
Nicolaus,
and hence also the pseudonym Balaam
given to Jesus in Sanhedrin 106B and
Gittin 57A.
All right. Now, with that said,
let me now show you what Peter Schäfer
says about the manuscript evidence,
and then I think we'll call it a wrap so
I can get ready.
Page 150, watch here.
Peter Schäfer, his scholarly work on
Jesus in the Talmud.
Jesus in the Talmud. He catalogs all the
extent manuscripts and compared, and he
shows many of them still have the name
Jesus intact.
But other copies of the same,
let's say,
reference,
they changed it because of the threat.
When the Christians found out the Talmud
has these negative references to Jesus,
they were threatened with persecution.
So, an edict went down in 1531. Gather
the copies, remove the names of Jesus,
and when you make fresh copies, don't
mention him anymore. But copies
predating the edict still survive.
So, don't lie to you, all right?
I just explained why, brother.
Astaghfirullah, did you been listening?
Why? I just said why, brother.
Because of the
awareness
by the Catholic Church that the rabbis
had derogatory, blasphemous
statements about Jesus and his holy
mother in the Talmud. And how were they
made aware of it? When Jews converted to
Catholicism.
Then the rabbis panicked, and an edict
went out in 1531. Go watch my series,
Jesus in the Talmud. I got a playlist.
Telling the Jews, remove references to
Jesus in the copies you find, and when
you make new copies, don't mention him.
But because we have copies of the Talmud
predating the edict, we find the name
Jesus there intact.
Okay? Let's go a little here.
Here you go. He catalogs them.
Right there, you see?
Notice that the manuscripts predate the
edict. The edict was 16th century, 1531.
So, glory to Jesus, these manuscripts
were preserved showing they are
referring to Jesus. So, he could then he
catalogs,
right?
And shows how there's a change. Before
the edict, these copies have the name of
Jesus.
After the edict, you see the same
statements in the same places don't have
the name of Jesus anymore.
And uh look, he catalogs it, okay?
Note
the manuscripts,
how
they're being edited. The earlier ones
clearly mention Jesus or something that
indicates it's Jesus.
But then the later ones after edict,
they change it.
See?
Here you go.
Oxford 23, the copy
of the Sabbath 104B, right here.
Was he the son of Stada and not the son
of Pandera? Because in rabbinic
tradition,
Jesus' biological father was a Roman
soldier named Pandera.
So, if you go watch part one in my
series,
and the reader article, I show you who
this is supposed to be, Jesus.
All right, so Vatican copy 108.
Okay, you noticing it?
Pandera, Pandera, Pandera.
Pandera, Pandera.
Right? So far intact.
And then his
mother's husband was Stada, but her
lover who got her pregnant is Pandera.
Look, the manuscripts they're showing
where these statements are there intact.
Here again.
Husband her husband was Pappos,
but her mother his mother's name was
Stada. Go watch part one. The rabbis
debated.
Is her husband's name Stada
or is her name Stada
and her lover Pandera?
Now watch here.
Husband Pappos, mother Stada, father
Pandera, husband lover Pappos, mother
Stada, he is Jesus the Nazarene.
You notice how this copy
right here
has Jesus the Nazarene?
You see? He's cataloging the evidence
for a change and how we know for certain
they're referring to Jesus because of
the copies
that were produced before the edict.
His mother Miriam, you see this copy it
says Miriam, right?
Mother Miriam.
And his father is who?
Nasi?
His mother was letting grow her woman's
hair.
Here so Soncino, his mother Miriam.
Vilna, his mother Miriam. See, we know
that's Jesus cuz his mother's name Mary.
Miriam.
His mother Miriam.
Mother Miriam Miriam.
All right.
Now this is interesting and in another
part when I do Jesus don't want I'm
going to deal with this as well.
All right.
I'm going to deal with where they
mention Jesus was the disciple of a
rabbi
whom the rabbi turned aside cuz Jesus
made a comment
about a woman that disgusted the rabbi
and he expelled him and cursed him and
then Jesus out of revenge went and
learned sorcery
and then misled people to follow him.
The rabbi came and begged him return. He
goes, "Well, he said it's too late for
me
that I won't be forgiven.
So there's no point in me repenting."
Right?
Exactly.
They call Mary a
who had unkempt hair like Lilith
the bride of Satan the demon
and that she got pregnant by a Roman
soldier named Pantiri Pandera
cheated on her husband and they call
Jesus a mamzer a bastard and were
anti-Semitic.
And were anti-Semitic, right?
Avery Vaughn, where are you at, bro?
You and David were going to do a live
stream exposing this?
No, I don't think so.
So notice here, I'm going to be doing a
session on this in the near future.
This myth, this tradition
that you will not have a son or disciple
like Jesus the Nazarene, see? The copy
mentions his name right there black and
white.
See that? All these copies, no doubt
they were talking about Jesus. But
notice this copy, the name is removed.
Notice this copy, the name is removed.
See what's going on here? The editing?
But God preserved
through the agency of these Jews enough
copies where they didn't remove the
references to Jesus.